oh yes hi guys and welcome to fright
diary it's a video where I just bask in
the warm glow of a laptop screen because
apparently I don't have regular lights
in my house Friday IRA is my week in the
life yeah it's my vlogs throughout the
week of things I've done this week I did
a particularly terrible job at capturing
moments so let's just get into it
are you making a moment goose I built
her in this dog house the other day and
she's definitely too big for it what a
week everyone gets a little bit oh Jesus
back in LA back in my car back headed to
meetings I'm getting better health-wise
not getting better at driving I am
getting now I could have finished ik
thoughts or sentences I didn't listen to
that song take me to church on repeat
constantly as a means to stimulate
create activity because that's how I
make myself creative and I've learned
that it's fun to listen to it if you
think when he's saying hey man hey man
and instead of amen if you seven gay men
it's a fun way to listen to it there's
tip of the day
Oh surprise surprise another day in Los
Angeles another day in my car another
day of meeting with the exciting
meetings I just got out of a meeting
with mamrie Hart actually I didn't film
it cause I got my face and it's about a
project that I'm really excited to show
you guys about soon how broken of a
record is that sentence I apologize but
now I'm on just second meeting and it's
beautiful outside today but just so I
have all the windows up in my car and
the air conditioning on yeah is exciting
oh hey oh hi hi fry diary look what I
found
just like a homeless person wearing a
Joan Rivers flipping off everyone
t-shirt style icon really truly we're on
our way to a top-secret meeting for
top-secret projects okay it's Thursday
and big things are happening
I got cable can you see any of that Hey
yeah look so cool that's happening Abed
is getting constructed upstairs
this aftermath of its or the present
mass of it had a great meeting today
about the television show all good
things are happening very excited and I
am going to get drinks with in helium oh
and Steve green tonight and they're
people that I like very much and I'm
very excited about that and there has
been your update
I don't oh that's on you
classic Thursday night we made some
dumplings and some pizza Bagel Bites
and there's a dog but once all of it no
matter what I know this Oh another day
in Los Angeles another day in my car in
Los Angeles I went out and had drinks
with Steve green and Nicky Lima last
night and they're just goddamn lovely
human beings a huge fan she thumbs up up
there her people and they didn't film it
because I'm just I guess I've made a
point to be really bad at vlogging this
week I headed over to Elliott Morgan's
place to shoot a video with him I'm
really excited I think he's one of the
funniest human beings and he speaks at a
level
it's almost Gilmore Girls esque it's
fast and furious and there's lots of
funny in there I just take a little bit
longer to decipher all of it and then
we're gonna go take a quick look at bust
me it has a new studio that they're
shooting out of so we're going to go
visit a sin y'all or as they Frank over
there does that did any of those words
mean anything to you
okay see you I just had a meeting at
BuzzFeed and
very interesting content really fishy
interesting content guys hey guys it is
Friday night I'm about to edit friary
and I already know this has been a very
it's been a very eventful week
I've just been awful at vlogging it I
apologize I went to BuzzFeed today that
was really great didn't film anything
inside of their shop with Elliott Morgan
that was really great didn't film
anything so this is a week of me just
telling you stuff that I'm doing and not
showing you anything how can i comp and
say quick house haul I just bought these
candleholders like this well oh sure
rocks and the candles going here
I mean don't forget if you like this
video - give it a thumbs up leave a
comment down below and subscribe so then
you don't have to seek me out on your
own there you can also do this with this
whoa I might beat that might have been
the most exciting thing that happened
this week I don't know I got super
market sushi which I am huge into I know
a lot of people out there think that
that's like not correct to eat sushi
that they make in supermarkets but
here's the thing I eat sushi for the
rice I say you know I should just be
eating tubs of sticky rice really it's
the reality of it glad we're getting
into this hard-hitting conversation
sometimes it's really hard to talk about
issues like this because it can be
really sensitive for a lot of people but
really glad that we are mature enough to
have this conversation